[Music]
avatar 2 the movie we had all thought
was never actually going to make it to
theaters now has an official release
date and title avatar the way of water
directed and produced by the legendary
filmmaker james cameron the way of
waters release date had been pushed back
seven times before landing on its
official release date later this year
and it's sure to be worth the wait as we
saw in a fantastic looking teaser
trailer back in may of 2022 now let's
get into everything we know so far about
avatar the way of water including the
upcoming film's amazing cast newly
revealed story lines and all the new
filmmaking technology created for this
otherworldly sequel
[Music]
the biggest question you probably have
is when is the release date and we're
happy to let you know that the film is
now confirmed to be released on december
16th 2022 13 years after the release of
the first avatar film which continues to
hold the record as the highest grossing
movie of all time pulling in over 2.8
billion dollars worldwide and this more
than paid for the all-in budget for the
four planned sequels for the film coming
in at a total budget of one billion
dollars or 250 million per movie rumored
titles for the third to fifth
installments in this series are avatar
the seedbear coming in 2024 avatar the
tolkien writer in 2026 and avatar the
quest for aw in 2028 the reason that
it's taken 13 years for us to finally
get a sequel lies in a series of
setbacks and a global pandemic in
october of 2010 cameron announced that
he was planning two sequels to his
original movie with release dates in
2014 and 2015. by 2013 though it was
announced that a fourth installment in
the franchise was in the works and would
be filmed at the same time as the others
pushing back the release date of avatar
2 to 2015 and then again to 2016 with
more delays at cinemacon in 2016 though
james cameron announced a fifth
installment was in the works as well and
once again pushed back the release date
to 2018. then with additional filming
delays due to technological issues it
was announced that the movie would have
to wait until 2020. in 2019 disney
bought fox which was set to produce
avatar 2 and announced the second film
would actually come later in 2021
finally amid the covid19 pandemic it was
announced that the film would be
released on december 16th of 2022 and
they have since stuck to their guns one
of the biggest reasons the filming took
so long was because a majority of the
movie is set to take place in or
underwater which places a lot of extra
strain on the production of the film
cameron didn't want to do dry wet
filming like you might see in movies
such as aquaman where they film actors
on a dry set hung up by cords and add in
cgi elements like bubbles and water
effects later he said they tried dry wet
filming and compared it to actual
underwater scenes and the difference was
astounding so with the film set to
actually be made in the water they had
to develop new motion capture technology
for the computer graphics the
reflections in the water caused the
mocap technology to not track the actors
faces properly so entirely new industry
altering technology had to be developed
another issue that arose was the
difficulty in removing scuba gear from
the actors faces and bodies in the
editing process so they had to learn to
hold their breaths for long underwater
scenes in the 900 000 gallon tank built
for the films the actors actually did a
pretty great job of holding their
breaths too with kate winslet breaking a
record for holding her breath and a
filmmaking performance beating out tom
cruise and mission impossible rogue
nation at over seven minutes long
certain storylines have been revealed
about the upcoming film which is set to
follow jake and nathiri's family several
years after the events of the first
movie a picture was released in 2017 of
seven young cast members of the film
most of whom are likely to be jake and
ethere's children including their
adopted human son spider who they
rescued from an rda facility according
to producer john landau jake took spider
in as his own but nati still somewhat
sees him as a member of the same race
that destroyed her home so there's
likely to be some interesting dynamics
at play here according to james cameron
the storyline in the sequels really
follows jake and nathiri and their
children it's more of a family saga
about the struggle with the humans
landau added that jake and nitiri's
family would be forced to leave their
home in the second film and explore the
further regions of pandora which will
likely lead us to the more water-based
areas of the planet and it's safe to
assume that this is where they'll become
acquainted with the aquatic-based na'vi
tribe known as the met kyina the cast
includes a number of newcomers as well
as returning actors such as zoe saldana
and sam worthington reprising their
roles as nati and jake sully other
returning actors include sigourney
weaver and stephen lang both of whose
characters died in the first film
sigourney weaver is expected to return
as a new navi character named kiri who
is actually one of jake and nathiri's
children while stephen lang is expected
to return as an avatar navi version of
himself perhaps with his mind and
consciousness uploaded soon after his
death into an avatar newcoming actors
include jack champion who will play jake
and nathiri's adopted son spider and
kate winslet who will play a member of
the water-based met kyna tribe named
ronal other newcomers include jamie
flatters playing jake and ethere's
firstborn son natalyam britain dalton as
their second son loac and trinity bliss
as taktiri their youngest child lastly
vin diesel and cj jones have joined the
cast and mystery roles while oona
chaplin will be playing a character
named varang while the exact run time
for the way of water is still
unconfirmed cameron revealed that the
unfinalized cut is over three hours long
and he doesn't want to hear any
complaints
i don't want anybody whining about
length when they sit and binge watch
television for eight hours cameron told
empire magazine this past july i've
watched my kids sit and do five one hour
episodes in a row here's the big social
paradigm shift that has to happen it's
okay to get up and go pee the first film
in the franchise had a runtime of two
hours and 40 minutes so we can probably
expect the second film to be at least
this long if not longer but that's
everything we know so far about avatar 2
so what are you most excited for in the
way of water drop your thoughts in the
comments section below also check out
the video on your screen for some more
of my content don't forget to like and
subscribe
and thanks for watching rocket riley
[Music]